what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here so guess what guys the Oscar
nominations for 2018 have been revealed
today I'm shooting by myself because if
you wake up John before 11:00 a.m. he is
grumpy it's not pleasant to be around I
have no idea who's been nominated a
hacker can guess who's been nominated on
some of these categories when I go
through this list right here see what's
up before I do that I wanted to give a
shout out to today's video sponsor that
is of course the Stardust app we've been
partnered up with Stardust for quite
some time now that's sponsored we've
ever had it's a app that lets you do
30-second reactions or reviews for any
film TV show or trailer and whenever
you're late to a review I've been
catching up on a lot of the awards
movies lately so having done a lot of
movie reviews on YouTube for them but we
do a lot of this Stardust posts over
there have over 120 posts right now with
4,000 followers a lot of your favorite
youtubers are on it including Tyrone
Magnus Jeremy John's the schmoes Wendy
Lee a flick pick late to the party it's
a great app and I highly recommend you
follow us first download the app follow
us verses we need to get more followers
in all of them we've post more than most
of them anyhow let's go through this
list guys so I'm looking at the variety
one right here Best Picture here we go
call me by your name that's an obvious
darkest hour
okay Dunkirk get out yes I'm so happy
get out got an Oscar nomination
Lady Bird good good fandom thread the
post the shape of water three billboards
outside Abbey Missouri well this all
seems like the ones that would have
gotten nominated the one that I wanted
to get an Oscar not was Logan don't see
it on here I'm not complaining about
this list I've seen all these movies
actually yeah they're all great films
well the one that I think I would like
to win out of all the Best Picture ones
is easily the shape of water and if
shape of water doesn't win really hoping
get out wins i did an oscar prediction
list with Rachel Cushing a week ago so
you can catch that whole thing there but
between this right here I'm really
helping shape of water rhythms lead
actor Timothy Hook call me by your name
Daniel for phantom thread of course
Daniel Cole oh sweet Daniel Cole ooh
yeah
for get out thank God he got nominated a
man woo I'm really really happy he got
nominated rightfully so gary oldman for
darkest hour Denzel Washington for rum
and Jay Israel looking at this I would
assume that Gary Oldman is probably
gonna win just like how he's been
winning pretty much all the awards this
list so far just release to categorise
I'm like yeah this seems like exactly
the ones who would get nominated and am
I surprised that James Franco is not on
this list I'm not surprised with all the
controversy that has been surrounding
him lately if I were to separate the art
from the artist I do think James Franco
deserves a nomination for that however
with all the crap he's been getting and
it seems like it's all pretty much true
I think they made the right choice this
year by not nominee nominee that would
just cause way too much controversy
after everything happened with Casey
Affleck last year it would not have been
a wise decision to have him nominate and
he's already gotten plenty of awards of
James Franco has his ego hurt don't
worry about it dude you want a bunch of
awards in the midst of all the crap
that's been happening with your life
it's your fault it's your fault man lead
actress Sally Hawkins the shape of water
Frances McDorman that's the one I'm
hoping wins for three billboards outside
having missouri margot robbie for it--
honest or she ronan for Lady Bird she's
great in that Meryl Streep for the post
it's easy to go of course Meryl Streep
got nominated but I saw the post
recently we did actually do a movie
review for that on YouTube she is
phenomenal in that movie it's not like
okay we get a Meryl Streep did another
big performance let's nominate her this
is a performance where she rightfully so
heard a nomination that being said
Frances McDorman deserves to win Best
Supporting Actor yes doing a quick scan
these are all the ones you would expect
Willem Dafoe for the Florida Project
Woody Harrelson and Sam Rockwell for
three billboards Richard Jenkins shape
of water at Christopher Plummer all the
money in the world
Rachael Cushing said that Willem Dafoe's
the one that she thinks will win Richard
Jenkins is the one I'd like to win Sam
Rockwell seems like he's most likely the
one who's gonna win that always found it
interesting in the supporting category
when two actors from the same movie or
both being nominated so they kind of
have to compete before that but even
looking back at three billboards I think
Sam Rockwell has the more stand
outperform
out of three billboards and if anyone's
likely to win this one at Sam Rockwell
and I have not seen all the money in the
world yet that is the one of the few
films I haven't seen Best Supporting
Actress mary j blige from mud down
Allison Janney I Tanya that's my
prediction right there Lesley Manville
for phantom thread Laurie Metcalf for
ladybird Octavia Spencer for the shape
of water oh cool Tavia spencer gotten on
him for the shape water I thought she
does a great job I didn't actually see
that coming but sweet Laurie Metcalf for
the ladybird it's a real toss-up for me
I think Laurie Metcalf and Lady Bird is
the performance I'm more Abbott ated
towards but I really think Allison
Janney for I Tonya is the one that will
probably win all right
director here we go dunker Christopher
Nolan of course get out get out I'm so
glad it's getting nominated it's crazy
now here's a fall center of the horror
category and I'm so happy it's getting
all these nominations yes Lady Bird
Greta Gerwig phantom thread Paul Thomas
Anderson the shape of water again we'll
del Toro you know I honestly thought
that get out would get a lot of snubs I
thought it would be the biggest
disappointment looks like the Oscars
have listened or the voters have
listened I'm really happy to see that
again at is at least getting all these
nominations on do I believe it'll
actually win these things I really doubt
it but I'm just happy to see that it's
at least getting recognized at the
Oscars even though I don't even really
watch the Oscars or the Golden Globes or
any of those things I do pay attention
to what's nominated I do pay attention
to what wins being nominated it is a big
sign of recognition so I'm so happy to
get out so far as getting all these
recognitions people did feel that Greta
Gerwig got snubbed from the Golden
Globes nomination especially when
ladybirds getting all these other
nominations so I'm really happy to see
that your Oscars paid attention and that
she did get nominated for Best Director
because after watching Lady Bird that is
a wonderfully directed film the
performances are amazing it takes a
great director to bring that to life as
well as great actors of course but it
does take a solid directors hand to be
able to do that really happy she
rightfully earned that nomination
animated feature the boss baby well
there's not a lot of animated features
the boss baby okay it's like they just
need you to fill that slot in there the
breadwinner Coco one of my favorite
movies of the year ferdinand and loving
Vincent you know I've heard a lot of
people rave about loving Vincent plenty
of people more people I know that are
real like film buffs who go to
check out the smaller films and loving
Vincent is a film that a lot of people I
know have been loving the hell out of
you know in my biased opinion I would
have to hope that Coco is the one to win
this one Best Adapted Screenplay call me
by your name course disaster Logan got
nominated for Best Adapted what that's
cool
that make that makes me really happy oh
that is so cool Logan got nominated for
Best Adapted Screenplay that makes me
really happy I wish I wasn't wearing my
DC shirt right now
Molly's game Aaron Sorkin of course
Aaron Sorkin mudbone okay whoa hmm I
feel like Molly's game has you know that
solid Aaron Sorkin script Logan to get
nominated for Best Screenplay weirdly
the this script is out of like directing
and acting and script I would put the
script as the third and that's not
saying the script is weak but I could
see why it's under the category of
adapted screenplay do I think it'll one
probably not I feel like between these I
feel like Molly's game's the one that
would probably win for Best Adapted
Screenplay
that's the original screenplay the big
sick get out oh yeah for some reason I
was really sold that get out would get
snubbed all across the board
Lady Bird the shape of water three
billboards for this one it's got to be
three billboards I think that has the
best dialog and while I disagree with
the way the movie ends I think it
absolutely deserves the Oscar still
cinematography Roger Deakins this better
be your year man this really better be
your a year for Blade Runner 2049
darkest hour that was something that I
was very much impressed by was the way
that film was shot because I just wanted
to watch Gary Oldman's performance then
I was watching the way the film was
capturing I was like well this movie
shot really well Dunkirk rightfully so
mud bound the shape of water ooh oh man
honestly the cinematography category
seems to be the toughest one for me to
decide because to me it's a toss between
Blade Runner 2049 Dunkirk and the shape
of water those tombs are all shot really
well I feel like Dunkirk would probably
be the third pick I would have to go
Blade Runner in 2014 now while shape of
water is the one I want to win Best
Picture shape water a shot beautifully
but Blade Runner 2049 has a couple of
factors and one of the things that
everyone can agree on is that film is
shot absolutely beautiful you know it's
one of those things where it's like
Roger Deakins just deserves to win at
this point film editing baby Dre
dunkirk I Tanya the shape of water three
billboards outside baby drivers duh
everyone knows baby drivers goin for
that one it asked although you know even
though Dunkirk was a little bit
confusing the first time I watched it
the second time I watched it I did
realize how brilliantly edited it is but
baby drivers a film that he's edited so
that one I think deserves to win sound
editing baby driver Blade Runner dunker
see I would give the sound editing to
Dunkirk on this one of course they threw
in Star Wars the last Jedi here but I
would give it to Dunkirk on that one it
might have been because of the IMAX
experience where I was really able to
absorb the sound that out of all them
Dunkirk was the one movie I saw this
year where and Blade Runner 2049
actually I think Blade Runner 2049 and
baby driver this sound design really did
stand out to me in Star Wars less Jedi
for sure but between all them Dunkirk
was the one when I saw a movie
especially on IMAX I kept talking about
the sound design on it sound mixing I
might actually give it to baby driver
okay best production design Beauty and
the Beast Blade Runner 2049 darkest hour
don't hurt the shape of water who for me
that's between Blade Runner 2049 in the
shape of water since I feel like shape
of water is gonna take the bigger hordes
home but the more prestige Awards I
would probably go a Blade Runner 2049 it
and the world and landscape is just a
lot larger ma'am that's tough I feel
like my heart's a little more gravitates
or a shape of water but my intellectual
side is a little bit more on the Blade
Runner 2049 Best Original Score here we
go
Dunkirk Khan's immer phantom thread the
shape of water stars last Jedi I would
go at Hans Zimmer's Dunkirk on Original
Score I mean the other ones here
nominated sound like Oscar songs you
know there's an argument you made about
that comments but Star Wars Lost Jedi
Dunkirk it was a great regular song it
was a haunting song but it does have
that epic orchestral type of music in
there that one to me is my favorite one
out of all of them and so I don't know
if Dunkirk would have the odds of
waiting for that one for Hans Zimmer I
would like it to win Best Original Song
okay this one I am standing by for sure
because they got Mighty River from my
bow mystery of love call me by your name
for me from cocoa stand up for something
marshal this is me the greatest showman
I did put out a tweet recently saying I
really hope this is me from the greatest
showmen wins the Oscar there's a great
history behind that specific song we did
a reaction to the video Raquel a cetl
performed it and which helped get the
movie greenlit it was so moving and
seeing the history behind that song
helping get that movie made was truly
moving and it is the best song in that
movie when I hear it it makes me cry so
yeah I really hope that wins makeup and
hair it's got to go to darkest hour man
it has to dude like when you watch that
movie you swear a Gary Oldman game to
[ __ ] on a weight and when balding you
like you haven't does not look like
makeup at all
costume design Beauty and the Beast yeah
I mean I don't know just bringing the
animation of life for the most part
darkest hour some good costume design
time thread deals with fashion so yeah
that makes sense shape of water I would
go shape of water on costume design and
visual effects Blade Runner 2049
guardians of the galaxy there's summer
blockbusters on the visual effect of
course the visual effects Blade Runner
20:49 guardians of the galaxy vol 2 Kong
Skull Island the last Jedi war for the
Planet of the Apes for me it would have
to be a toss-up between Blade Runner
2049 and war for the Planet of the Apes
I mean though Blade Runner 2049 has some
more flashy visual effects probably a
bigger variety of visual effects war for
the Planet of the Apes the fact that
you're watching a bunch of mocap is so
believable at times you swear you're
looking at real Apes part of the
believability and impact of that film is
you have to believe these Apes are real
and that movie really does do that
although it is the third installment
where they had time to master that I
think they might go with Blade Runner
2049 for this one I would probably go a
war for the Planet of the Apes for me
it's a real tiebreaker seeing blade
foreigner 24 for the Planet of the Apes
but in terms of the biggest AMA nations
from Best Director Best Picture Best
Actress Best Actor all those are pretty
obvious nominations everyone pretty much
saw these ones coming will really
surprise me about this nomination list
is how much get out was recognized I am
super super happy it is and also I'm
glad that you know while I would have
liked Lowe going to get nominated for
directing or picture or you
jackman for Best Actor I'm happy that at
least it took time to recognize it and
throw it in for Best Adapted Screenplay
because that is a pretty big tear for
comic book movies to hit I mean seeing
comic book movies and like the visual
effects Department is not a surprise to
see it in Best Adapted Screenplay that
is super cool yeah looking forward to
these Oscars I can't wait to see the
list of winners probably attend some
friends Oscar party and watch long and
get drunk anyway guys between all these
categories what are your picks put them
down in the comment box below and let us
know what you think you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up and make
sure to download the Stardust app and
follow us first at the real rejects
people do it